if one of your girls wants out she just
decides she's done with his life and
wants to quit
is that an option for her
okay i'm sorry what's your name again
you can call me niko cuckoo
and one or two i go by hand one on okay
all right uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i grew up in
miami tennessee
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents yeah i ain't
bought with my parents and i lost my dad
you know till he had hard trouble you
know and
you know my mama she stayed strong as a
black lady and she came and tried to
continue to do the business
give me and my suits with a good life
it's like 13 of us
but my other brothers in chicago they
chose to stay up there you know what i'm
saying so i
me and my sisters came we we we stayed
here we didn't leave
yeah and uh how far you going to school
i made it to the 11th grade
yeah and i got kicked out because you
know
i started early like you know i started
early
easy fast money you know and if you
remember
you familiar with me making easy money
and pimping hoes and stuff
so you know this had come about so it
ain't no reason why a person should say
it's not dirt or things ain't you know
to your ability and movies because
memphis is a distribution who
everything has to come through here so
it's kind of easy to kind of catch on
then you know me being so young and i'm
in the streets
i put everything else on the back burner
and went straight forward with
you know pimping holes and all that you
know and then
i kind of you know made my momma and
daddy smile before he look i want to get
my ged
you know what i'm saying and i went from
there
and and like i said as early as like 16
years old
i had my first hole at 16. who who
taught you the game
really i came in like you know i came in
it's a you know when you
when you're in the streets and you move
around and big dogs see potentially you
they kind of put you on their wings it's
kind of like a father-son
thing if you got a good night into the
street you see what i'm saying
and when i came about you know then
cause i wasn't even old enough to get in
the strip club
you see what i'm saying but my face car
was so good
i just walked clean through you know
ain't no id no searching no nothing
and i went straight in and when i went
straight in you know i knocked the first
whole night was
kiki paradise there was a street stage
night in paradise
and it was a guy by the name of
freestyle you know what i'm saying and
freestyle treatment on these wings he
had like six holes you know what i'm
saying
he took me on his wings and he showed me
where i was went wrong and showed me
what i don't do and he's like
when because when you when you come
about with the game of pimping or
whatever because
if this holding on to somebody else but
then she want to lead him and come to
you
you can't do that because it's not right
you have to get her
and him and you have to go it's a word
called serve i had like you sure like
that
like you get kicked out your house and
they have to serve you your papers
before you
to leave or get evicted so i had to go
get up i didn't notice
i had to take her me i had to go to him
and serve him and let him know
that this is no longer your host she
belongs to me she paid me
you have to pay pay him no she paid me i
just had to serve him and let him know
as at this hour this day and then they
did
you can't don't say nothing to her don't
put your hands on her you could just
stretch off your roster because she's no
longer your hoe she chose people she
chose
she chose me she walked in sit down for
about an hour
she walked up and said on my lap and
told me i've been watching you since you
came here
and she said i want to go home with you
i said baby i don't do that because you
know to me
being a young street [ __ ] i kind of
thought it was like a setup thing
because she just came out the blue and
kind of tell me she want to go home with
me and all these dreams
and she's a pretty looking girl so i
know she got a pimp so i'm thinking it's
the game you see was saying but the
whole time she was on some
you really want she seen potentially me
so she gave me her money back you know
the little things in the strip club
they had these little bags around they
raised me like money she took it off and
handed it to me
and i wanted to serve him and from that
day forward that was my first hope they
were that was my very first hurdle when
i was 16 years old
how many girls do you have now i have
like i really
to be honest i had like six girls right
but when i had like my bottom my bottom
girl and
two other girl they make more noise than
ten girls together
so i don't need all the housing i got
three main lines and
they they they working and
you would think i got 14 15 home the way
they move
you see what i'm saying how much does
each girl bring in tonight probably on a
slow night
we probably do like on a slow drive
because i tell them three days
we ate this is my motto three days on a
slow day we ate
because if you charge in four filthy
just for a conversation
so when they get on to want to do
details and see knows and do all the
edges though
it's about an hour and my girls they're
not cheap they three feet don't build up
you see you're saying so
on on a bad night i probably do like 25
on it
you know what and i bid in my home boy
because he was like man you ain't
chicken 2500 on the city man without
getting on the computers
you know we like see everything going up
and down the highway you see what i'm
saying but i turned my girls on to this
thing
called sugar daddy.com and they made a
lot of
treats but they were not considered
trees they were like their clients
and they were like on sugardead.com
you tell a little bit about yourself and
what you're looking for and these guys
are already on there looking for
certain things and ain't no [ __ ]
like
everybody on there really papered up
like i know like you
to be talking to a man he tell you well
go to the airport i'm gonna give you and
send you a ticket
i'm on my yacht they're gonna drop you
off in florida and i'll be at the heart
when they pick you up that type of [ __ ]
this is how they get down they rich
they they don't you know what i'm saying
like my girl name
miss behave she had an old she got an
old dude
named jim they kind of tied in with like
the
you know chick-fil-a [ __ ] [ __ ] like her
jew you know what i'm saying they might
get her 500 just to come out there to
the cow he pulled up
pour her shirt up let her see your teeth
and he gone
so twenty five hundred dollars a night
all three of your girls will bring in or
each one
yeah no on them but you say it on a slow
night yeah
like 2500 i'd be cool with it without
each girl
but now each girl probably the minimum
like 1200 you're cool
if it's like it ain't picking up
beatings but you just just stay out
there and try at least make a thousand
dollars man
because we got to go forward we can't go
backwards so we got a thousand and we
putting it up
we can think about that we can make
plans now it ain't no minimum we
we're trying to do it big a little bit
like you know thinking about tomorrow
and all that we ain't thinking about
today you see what i'm saying
you have different races of girls no i
have i get i had one bilingual she was
vietnamese and black you know
but she ended up her grandmother took
sick so she ended up going back to
vietnam with her grandmama
you know what i'm saying but when she
comes to the city she come home you know
what i'm saying but
she's just you know like you consider
her like a six man
she is needed you see what i'm saying
she's on the bench until you need
like we don't really even think of
nothing but when she come home she still
come and contribute to the campaign you
know what i'm saying we just straight
profit
ent this is my that's me you know what
i'm saying
and do you have sex with your girls my
mind
you know then my mind because one thing
about it if a [ __ ] get to have too much
sex with them they get to get in
feelings like we girlfriend and
boyfriend in which we not
we are what you consider business
partners
so tonight michael's trying to you know
i ain't gonna say it ain't never i
almost went there but i had to catch
myself
because if that's what it's about then
they'll get to get mislead because
they're thinking wait i don't get his
money and i live when i come home and
and do this and do that he'll forget
about it now you know that he ain't
gonna be so hard on me because this is
my dude
no see you got to keep me with the
business man if i don't come home with
his money i'm gonna get fired i'm gonna
feed my kids as long as you keep them on
18
and all that feelings and [ __ ] don't get
to getting water down it stays the same
you see what i'm saying but if you get
them having sex with all along
you know how to go you're giving them
good sex and feelings come about
and you don't want them to have feelings
like i don't want to do it with him and
i because this is what they hear they
hold they lay on their back for money
they talking they got them whatever your
customer clown want that's how you get
it
so like i said at the end of the day you
can't
stick your dick in everything that you
can sit in your home because they will
be misled and
they won't be about what you want them
to be about
as long as you keep them on game and
teach them this and teach them in the
teaching
they learn and so they feeling like a
child going to school he's going to
leave it to his teacher because he's
learning and succeeding
so if i'm keeping her with the game he's
paying off every time every time
she feels like she's i'm going to treat
her life you see what i'm saying she's
coming back home
for more and more and she's you know
she's going
she gonna ride it out with me because it
was from the bottom to the top
so the girl gives you all the money she
gives me everything and then she'll be
like well
i need to take my kids these and this we
sit down and make a
megalist you know you took these out the
pot you took these out of the pot you
took these at the pot
like these these mothers christmas so
everything they took out the pot to go
crippling shoveling now
it's being tatted up you see what i'm
saying so
it ain't no walking around here with a
big bang rolling
now it's needed you see what i'm saying
so it's critical you're going to go
criminal shopping
who go 500 that's more than enough so
i'm expecting it'll be ain't no receipts
coming back with no
hell of numbers on it i'm expecting some
change back you know what i'm saying
so as long as they come every season
they add up i'm i'm cool with it
you know what i'm saying and it just did
on it you see what i'm saying
yeah and then the laws have changed in
this game so it's a much more dangerous
thing for you right exactly you in
prison time
yes before for you know
my main thing was i'm very very laid
back you know what i'm saying but
that's why you see me now my company and
my sis circle has gotten so small
because when i was around so many dudes
i kind of was getting knocked out by the
police
the narcotics the knockout they
currently come and hit my spot
but this because i was slick straight in
the fence i was still selling dreams and
pimping
so i'm pimping but i'm selling dreams so
when they come in and out you know what
i'm saying they thinking then now they
got the conclusion that i'm picking but
then
i got a whole house going on but really
it's jews being sold and all this so
they coming you know what i'm saying and
i didn't get knocked out plenty of times
hundred thousand born 250 i don't know i
had to sit down for like two years
i didn't been through it so now i just
keep it like this basic and discreet you
know what i'm saying
my whole they go out of town they get
they beating this like we mean
they go to the legal state where
prostitution is legal is no
problem the mayan thing is
sure but they got some found they got
[ __ ] so laid down with the blueprint
in like vegas and all it they got
regulars
so they go up there do they think you
know what i'm saying do they think it's
nothing to
straight or drive you know what i'm
saying and get their money you know what
i'm saying and they come back like on
the vacation type [ __ ] you know what
they
they've gone back but all through the
city i have never
like my hoes have been caught up for
prostitution but it's not no regular
thing because i don't have street
walkers
i don't have girls put on here and go
out there and walk the streets they on
another level with it you see what i'm
saying they phone ringing
people calling demanding them requesting
them you see what i'm saying
so you know other than that it's like
you your girls use drugs no i i keep
them i keep them clean because
if you have a girl on drug a man ain't
stable her mind is not
where you want to be and then you trying
to keep on gang and tell
these but yeah you did it but the drug
you don't make her feel like the drugs
so
she really not listening to you she
hustling for the drugs now
so if you let her get addicted to drugs
you making a mistake cause she's not
hustling to please you
she hustling to make sure she keeps them
dope and that ain't what's going on
you see what i'm saying dopes make whole
hair cloudy minds
they can't think right and stable and
locked tight that's how that's how you
want them all them girls on drugs and
shooting up and
uh this this is a whole nother chapter
and i ain't with it
i'm just gonna be honest if one of your
girls wants out she just decides she's
done with his life and wants
to quit is that an option for her
i ain't gonna say i'm gonna be hard on
him if a girl comes to me right now
and you know girls i didn't you know
i've been doing this for two years i
just really want to announce just
go give me a job and go raise my keys
you know what i'm saying
i got a hard sweet cause i got keys so
i'm not gonna tell you her
[ __ ] now hold you gonna go do this
[ __ ] ain't gonna i
i don't use these i use this you see
what i'm saying so
if then what she want out and she has
helped me and helped me do it
i can't not have a big life i appreciate
you everything you have done for me
and she's gone you know then there's not
no death blood in blood out thing
because
you got people that get changed lives
they want to go home and be a mother to
their family
so you can't fault them for this and i
feel like if this is what you want
you being very very stubborn you know
what then because
you had a good life and you wanted your
mama so why you think these kids don't
wanna say mama
you're already being stubborn have her
away from her knees alone so you kind of
got the fuss yourself but even if she
doesn't have kids and just wants out
now if she don't want to get kids and
just want out
i still kind of straddle the fence
because if she's on a positive road like
she's sick of this and want to go get a
degree in ireland
it's all type of other things the person
wants to do besides
horn and and doing all these such things
so
you can't just say what a person want to
do but it's a problem she telling me
she gonna leave me for him or him and
him because
[ __ ] i i i brought you to where you is
no you want nothing without me
so now i got you looking good now you
won't leave me thought you're going to
go to another
i ain't never had that problem because i
lead i'm a great leader
you see what i'm saying i'm a very great
leader which means
as long as you're a great leader you're
gonna forever have followers
you see what i'm saying and that's how i
go you know what i'm saying
what are you proudest of in your life
huh what are you proudest of
in your life my sister don't like how
like like like for thanksgiving we just
gave away turkeys and all that you see
what i'm saying
my contributors back to the projects in
the hood because i ain't
like i can't say i just had no rough
life but i didn't have no rich and
famous life
so i know how people out here struggling
and i have a heart
and i'm thankful for the heart i have
and a lot of people help
i'm just not taken from society because
i consider myself a plea or
that's just the way i manage to get my
money but i also help
and all the other things so i'm just not
getting the money you know some
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] are my mother oh you
can't get no i'm very grateful
i had to have a good heart you know what
i'm saying
i'm not gonna down i'm talking about
none of that and now
i'm just proud of the person i became
because i could have went left because
drugs had stopped being
a part of my life at one point in time
but i started losing more
so i had to like it's like if i'm gonna
stay focused and stay clean and do my
thing that's what i'm gonna do but if
not you're gonna lose everything so
i had to stand firm and when i when i
kicked it out it hurt it for a minute
because
it would it would make you feel good but
one thing this model right here i keep
in my head and
to never go back their way it hurts so
bad
but it feels so good
meaning the dope have you feeling great
but it hurts so bad because it breaks up
happy homes
your family and all on it but you
so gone out the dope and feeling good
you ain't even thinking about that
[ __ ] them you thinking about your next
hat no i can't do that
i i got other people depending on me so
this is the way i
that's the way i i had to you know plant
my roots and not let them grow
anytime some suffer i'm with it i ain't
i ain't i'm not on it like i'm not on it
i can't be on it
because i have kids and they love they
did and all of it
so are you raising your kids no they
with their mother but i'm in their life
i take care of my kids they're not
wanting for anything
you you've uh been in love before yeah
he's a young one and then like
like right now love is not a thing that
money's more important no because money
ain't everything
love don't love no better though and
it's a such thing now it's loyal to
overlord
i'd rather you be lower to me than just
constrain you love me
because long as you loyal to me you're
gonna do all the things that love makes
you do
you see what i'm saying so loyalty is
the
word i use not love and you've been
doing this how old are you now
i'm 35 you've been doing it since 16.
yes sir how has the game changed
tremendously because you got young girls
running away from home trying to do
these in life at the age
and at one point in time you had to show
your id and all that [ __ ] don't need
curse she said she wanna do that they
let him come along
and it's hurting the game because he's
making it hard on the people that's
going the right way about the things
that they do
and they feel like everybody in screen p
they're evil and all that and it's not
right they just looking at the people
that put the bad jacket on now back
so we have to you know you still have to
go straight and follow
and and do it firm and make people
strong believe it
it is everybody duties is not a bad
person
you know what i'm saying and everybody
do these and go this way
they're not a killer or the devil and
all that because
i don't think like him or i don't act
like him
i think like myself and i make my own
decisions
so you know other than that the game
the game ain't really changing just the
people in it
you know what i'm saying exactly what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life speak like others
but i always have my mind my own main
idea
and think like myself because if i let
you see my hand
i ain't bluff you out but if i speak
like you
you thinking i get proud of the same
thing and you ain't got a winner but the
whole time
i gotta flush i did with y'all calling
in poker so he's really like
i'm not tricking you but i'm really not
gonna show you my hand because
i can't this is like we only we we we
battling with a
like like like family furious or
something we currently giving answers
and then like we each both trying to get
that money but
every time a question asks i give you
the answer and i get an answer so both
of us get the answer right
no it got to be a wrong in the right you
see what i'm saying both of us can't
answer the question right
one of those might either answer the
question and then answer
is bringing more points than the
question answer you get but you still
get it right and you thought like
yourself so
you should feel good within yourself
that didn't nobody help you do this or
nothing it just came about on your own
you see what i'm saying and once people
get that in their head they're gonna be
so much better
with life or anything you do because
this plays a part in
everything it's just not one thing is
everything
yeah what advice would you give to a
young man who's considering doing this
kind of work if he got a chance to stay
positive like me
if i would have never got distracted
with the streets i probably would have
been pro right now and playing
basketball
you know what i'm saying but i got so
distracted and started smoking and
stopping my growth all that stuff you
know then so
if you got another way and another way
out go for
it because anything about it i hate to
say nothing we doing right you see what
i'm saying
so anything you're doing wrong you know
you got to look over your back
and all that and that ain't what you
want
you want to be able to go home whatever
you do for nobody to worry about the
police doing this and then
everything's just the right way so you
got a chance to do better and not want
to be around these and do this
get your wife start your family love
them and do them right and go back in
right
and god will bring you so much more
you have to ever have to uh straighten
out some of your girls they've got
headstrong or they get ideas of their
own you ever have to
rough them up like they get to smell and
they say i mean
if i get to telling them stuff and i
don't be aggressive with that late man
they think that i'm
getting soft on all this so i have to
rough them up and let them know that nah
i ain't gonna stop i'm just giving you a
leeway
i don't have to be in your face and
doing this all the time to make you do
right if i speak this
no matter what type of voice i use if i
put bass in the night
if i speak it out my mouth that's what i
want this is what needs to be done
you know what i'm saying and simple as
that
yeah all right man thank you so much for
sharing your story and talking with me
and uh yeah thank you man
hopefully we meet again yeah man thank
you all right
you